this past Saturday we aired our Conan in  Haiti special and while we were in Haiti  we offered Haitians their own version of  make America great again hats it's a hat  that says Haiti is great already we  offered it to them and they were quite  happy to have it people really like the  slogan in Haiti they liked it so much so  that omae's calm is now exclusively  offering this Haiti is great already  t-shirt to raise money for two amazing  charities that help Haiti and Haitian  people j/p HRO and artists for peace and  justice so go to omae's calm slash Haiti  to by this great t-shirt and help out  the people of Haiti it really does make  a difference  [Applause]  you